if I can use Ai and autonomy to continue
to increase the capabilities of every
individual fighter pilot every
individual bomber pilot every individual
operator out there and that's what's
going to keep America at the top of our
game some of the hesitation around
adoption of AI really comes down to the
hesitation to any set of new tools when
it's introduced into a mission critical
application um you know throughout
military history and especially the
American way of of exercising military
power we're always looking for the edge
that we can get with our material our
training our our Concepts our Doctrine
that's going to allow us to
Prevail with any tool and AI is just one
great example what the operator wants is
something that's reliable that's
trustworthy and it's not going to open
up additional vulnerabilities in their
operations or the way they do business
AI is a complex system there's no
shortage of EXP exposure you know every
article on uh you know the new large
language models or something like that
that show potential un unintended
interactions uh that comes part and
parcel with these systems uh I believe
that you know we have a long history of
doing very disciplined tests being able
to understand uh the performance and the
limitations of a system and then
effectively communicate that out to our
war Fighters you know continuing to
invest in our test infrastructure and
the the people and uh the systems that
do that testing is absolutely critical
to feel this technology Ai and autonomy
is a new Middle Ground where the
technology is the tactic and so we have
to have operational style testing with
developmental rigor uh and that's going
to take some investment in our overall
test infrastructure I'd say overall at
epsi we're just passionate about
unlocking this capability for America
the way that we've been doing business
of buying small numbers of incredibly
expensive but incredibly effective
systems it just doesn't scale anymore at
the same time what we've seen in Europe
Europe and other theaters is that you
know they've democratized Warfare a
thousand drone can take out a a
multi-million dollar asset we want to
make sure that America stays at the
front edge of this to that end we pursue
really any method possible in order to
build uh and sell these capabilities
continue to grow our
company every weapon system has both an
offensive and a defensive capability it
is important to realize that computer
science Ai and autonomy is being worked
on across the globe uh and for every
Advance we make uh other nations are are
making those similar advances the speed
pace of innovation and our ability to
test in fields new capabilities is
what's going to continue to provide the
United States The Edge uh every time
that we take a step uh whether it's a
slowed budget a delayed program decision
that slows down our ability to field
these systems we're giving our
adversaries the opportunity to take the
Head
Start I think all of our Fighters are
always concerned with the threat uh
where they are today and where they're
going and that obviously includes Ai and
autonomy uh the answer is that we
continue to develop and field our own
systems so that we can maintain the edge
that America's enjoyed on the
battlefield